[Música]
yo no quería ser un emprendedor social
porque iba a querer ser un emprendedor
social a los 24 años trabajando en el
sector financiero
era director de banca de inversión de un
grupo importante en méxico y en un mes
ganaba más que mi padre en un año
cuando cumplí 40 años
me sentía realmente
en la cúspide de la pirámide
una inmensa casa en bosques de las lomas
con más de mil metros cuadrados de
construcción
casa en vallecas en acapulco
departamento en miami hasta un
departamento en europa tenía
coleccionaba coche presionaba relojes
coleccionaba cuadros y arte
pero un día hace ocho años todo cambió
un día saliendo de mi oficina
corporativa donde ya manejaba yo mis
propios negocios
se para un coche
bajaron tres individuos de él y a golpes
le subieron
estaba detenido
y de ahí me llevaron al reclusorio de
puente grande donde pasé un año en
presión
yo soy jorge cueto soy actuario egresado
la universidad anáhuac soy padre de
cinco hijos pero también soy un ex
convicto
esta es una imagen de cuando yo estaba
un poco más joven
las cárceles en méxico no son como nos
las cuentan en las películas
ese mito de que entras a la cárcel con
tu verón naranja y te dan tus toallas
tus sábanas tu almohada y tu papel de
baño hasta arriba y así vas entrando es
la mentira más grande
las cárceles en méxico son
muy diferentes las cárceles en méxico
son terribles
son digámoslo así lo más cercano que
pueda haber al infierno
en ese año que viví dentro de la cárcel
sujeto a proceso
porque aquí en mexico ya saben que hasta
hace poco todos sabíamos culpables hasta
que pudiéramos demostrar nuestra
inocencia me pude dar cuenta de cómo se
vive en las cárceles de nuestro país
como la violencia como la corrupción
como la tortura es pan nuestro de cada
día
y lo que todavía es peor
es que una vez que se obtiene la
libertad
es muy difícil poder reinsertarse
nuevamente
la mayoría de los muchachos y muchachas
que hoy en día están en la cárcel la
verdad es que no tienen una educación no
tienen herramientas para la vida no
tienen estructura familiar y no tienen
el interés del gobierno pero lo que sí
tiene es una carta de antecedentes
penales que evita que el 99.9 de las
grandes empresas en este país los
contraten
aunado a eso tenemos hoy en día un
problema que todos ustedes lo saben no
es necesario saberlo o sea decirlo
tenemos más de 400 grupos de crimen
organizado que están constantemente en
expansión
400 grupos de crimen organizado de
narcotraficantes y extorsionadores
huachi coleros etcétera etcétera
etcétera
que todo el tiempo están queriendo
contratar más gente
imagínense qué situación estamos
viviendo hoy en día una sociedad que
rechaza a la gente que va saliendo de la
cárcel y una serie de grupos de crimen
organizado que están ansiosos por
contratarlos
hoy en día en méxico hay más de 200.000
personas en la cárcel
y de esos 200.000 van a salir libres
este año 35 mil
35000 personas con antecedentes penales
que se van a sumar las que salieron en
el 2019 en el 2020 en el 2018 y que se
van a sumar las del año que viene
estamos hablando de un problema de
cientos de miles de mexicanos que hoy en
día no pueden tener una vida normal
que no pueden trabajar como ustedes
debido a esta circunstancia y eso que
pude yo ver dentro de la cárcel se creó
el concepto de prisión art
visión es un proyecto que tiene como
objetivo
darles una
mejor esperanza de vida a todas las
personas que van saliendo de la cárcel a
estos muchachos y muchachas y nótese que
siempre digo muchachos y muchachas
porque el 70% de la población carcelaria
en nuestro país tiene entre 19 y 29 años
el 70% se ha
140.000 personas son menores de 29 años
en la cárcel una generación completa la
tenemos ahí
tratamos darles un futuro más
esperanzador tratamos de darles a ellos
a sus familias una mejor esperanza de
vida
tratamos de disminuir la estigmatización
a la que es sometido este grupo de
personas
y claro en el camino y si funciona bien
lo que queremos hacer
estaremos disminuyendo los índices de
violencia y de delincuencia que hoy en
día no están aquejando tanto y como lo
hacemos porque suena como muy padre
decir a qué bueno no cómo funciona este
proyecto este proyecto que se inició en
puente grande tiene un programa de tres
pasos básicamente primero es
capacitación como les decía hace un
momento la mayoría de los muchachos y
muchachas que están en la cárcel no
saben hacer nada
pues la primera parte de la capacitarlos
y el gran reto era encontrar a algo que
a ellos les llamara la atención
porque efectivamente los gobiernos
tienen la obligación de dar cinco cosas
comida hecho dentro de la cárcel
educación trabajo deportes que creen que
dan algo de comida algo de techo algo de
deportes capacitación y trabajo es
prácticamente imposible entonces
iniciamos con un proceso de capacitación
para enseñarles algo hay un programa de
rehabilitación para darles herramientas
para que ellos puedan rehabilitarse a sí
mismos porque nosotros no rehabilitamos
a nadie la rehabilitación es una
cuestión interna es un acto de voluntad
de los muchachos y finalmente y cuando
obtienen la libertad nosotros les damos
una oferta laboral para que vengan a
trabajar con nosotros
cuando yo estaba en la cárcel y quise
iniciar este proyecto para tratar de
solucionar esta problemática que tanto
nos aquejan tuve la idea de hacer una
asociación civil de pedir dinero
prestado de pedir donativos de pedir
apoyos del gobierno para que realmente
pudiéramos solucionar esto después de
pensarlo bien dije esto es imposible
nadie me va a querer dar un peso a una
sociedad mexicana tan violada tan
asaltada tan agredida tan constantemente
durante tantos años no iba a haber
posibilidad de que alguien quisiera dar
un donativo para esta causa o sea si
ustedes hacen la lista de todos los
donatarios que pueden recibir un
donativo siempre primero serán los niños
después para bajo los ancianos
enfermedades proyectos ecológicos
ambientales y seguimos hacia abajo
perritos en la calle y más y más abajo y
más abajo quizás el último sería las
personas privadas de la libertad
creamos un concepto de productos hechos
en la cárcel por personas privadas de la
libertad
que creó una marca de lujo hicimos una
fusión un poco extraña
entre
arte marroquinería diseño de moda y
tatuaje que tuvo como resultado una
serie de productos de lujo muy
importante esto del lujo que compiten
hoy en día contra las grandes marcas
internacionales estos productos son
productos de piel ya que aprendimos a
hacer un tengo un sistema en el cual
somos capaces de tatuar el cuerpo el
mismo procedimiento que se hace para
tatuar el cuerpo humano que nosotros
tratamos cuero y con ese cuerpo tatuado
se arman piezas como chamarras tenis
carteras mochilas juegos de mesa
etcétera etcétera etcétera
con una característica sumamente
importante que como es un tatuaje se
hace una sola vez qué quiere decir que
cada pieza es única e irrepetible
o sea hacemos un diseño de una bolsa
como la que está en la pantalla y de esa
bolsa o mejor se hacen 100 pero cada una
combinará diferentes colores de piel con
diferentes tatuajes tratando de promover
la individualidad tanto del que hace la
bolsa como de aquel que lo va a usar
el proyecto
fue muy es muy ambicioso no es lograr
que presionar esta marca esta marca
hecha por exconvictos y por gente que
está en la cárcel realmente pueda
competir contra las grandes marcas de
lujo italianos y francesas tratamos de
utilizar los mejores materiales que
están a nuestro alcance los mejores
diseños la mejor arte para poder tener
un producto que se venda en boutiques
hoy en día hemos desarrollado una serie
de canales de distribución que tenemos
tiendas propias tenemos alrededor de 11
tiendas propias que están ubicadas donde
están las grandes marcas tenemos un
envasar y tenemos en san miguel de
allende tenemos en valle de bravo
tenemos en cancún tenemos en cozumel
pero también hemos empezado a abrir
tiendas fuera de mexico ya tenemos en
barcelona tenemos en parís tenemos en
austria tenemos en alemania la primera
franquicia tenemos córneas dentro de
hoteles también no es una red de
distribución
que tiene como objetivo un doble
objetivo y esto es muy importante porque
muchas veces me preguntan en jorge
porque el lujo porque no existe otra
cosa dentro de la cárcel puede ser hecho
muebles podría ser hecho ropa más
sencilla artesanías carcelarias y
realmente dice diseñamos el proyecto
para que vendiera el lujo por dos
objetivos el primero es el margen
somos una empresa social nos
autodenominamos con una empresa social
pero también somos una empresa
tradicional qué quiere decir esto que
nosotros necesitamos ganar dinero
porque nosotros no recibimos donativos
ni apoyos de nadie o sea todo lo que
logramos hacer es a través del esfuerzo
y de las ventas que tenemos de los
productos que realizamos
el lujo nos da un margen más grande lo
cual nos permite ganar más dinero pero
el segundo punto y que es muy importante
es un cambio de perspectiva que buscamos
que la gente tenga el momento que entra
en nuestras tiendas
cuando una persona entra una de nuestras
boutiques sobre los productos no
queremos que nos los compre por lástima
queremos que los compres porque
realmente es un producto super deseable
super apetecible al más alto al más alto
nivel de la moda al más alto nivel de
diseño
pero también tiene una cosa muy
importante que es cuando una persona
entra y sabe que ese producto fue hecho
por una muchacha en el penal de
tulancingo o en el penal de querétaro
como hacemos ciertas partes de la
joyería etcétera
cambia la perspectiva dice como o sea
esto lo hizo una persona que está
privada de su libertad entonces una
persona no es basura no es desechable
no o sea esa es la parte que queremos
demostrar a través de estos productos
que tienen un discurso propio y por lo
tanto se venden a través de boutiques
porque tiene que ser el producto el lujo
debe ser vendido a través de una
boutique como les decía nosotros nos
consideramos una empresa social
también queremos ganar dinero la
diferencia entre nosotros y una empresa
tradicional es que hace con ese dinero
las empresas tradicionales fueron
diseñadas para crear riqueza ya venden
productos vender servicios generan
riqueza y enriquecen a los
inversionistas
en nuestro caso es el dinero que
nosotros ganamos lo utilizamos para
crecer el modelo de negocio y así poder
generar más impacto
qué quiere decir esto si el modelo
funciona si los productos son buenos si
conseguimos ganar mercado abrir puntos
de venta etcétera ayudaremos a más gente
si consigo duplicar el tamaño de la
compañía podría aumentar el doble de
personas beneficiadas en el proyecto hoy
en día tenemos cerca de 200 personas en
el programa de reinserción social
de las cuales 42 ya están en libertad y
trabajando con nosotros en nuestras
oficinas en nuestra planta en nuestros
talleres
otros 140 y tantas están todavía
privados de libertad pero esperando a
que salgan para que se puedan
reincorporar con nosotros
y como empresa social aparte de medir
los resultados del estado de resultados
y el balance que miden las empresas
tradicionales nosotros tenemos que medir
también que tan bien estamos haciendo la
cosa que también estamos generando el
impacto social que queremos hacer por lo
tanto nosotros también queríamos aparte
de los digamos estados financieros
auditados creamos nuestro reporte de
impacto y ese reporte de impacto ha
arrojado números sumamente interesantes
el 89 por ciento de los participantes no
han vuelto a reincidir qué quiere decir
salen de la cárcel y no vuelven a
cometer un delito se mantienen libres de
drogas desarrollan actividades el
programa funciona pero lo que es más
interesante
según datos en la secretaría de
gobernación una persona que vive en
actividad delictiva puede cometer hasta
dos delitos diarios
pisando el que asesina lo que secuestra
pero si el que vende drogas si el que
vende guache calls y el que asalta en
las combis son los microbuses etcétera
usado una cuenta hoy en día tenemos 200
personas en el proceso de reinserción
multipliquen la por dos delitos diarios
por 365 días al año
son 146 mil delitos menos que estamos
tratando de solucionar o de evitarlo
pero si todo funciona bien y podemos
crecer el modelo de negocio en 5 años
podríamos tener 1400 personas dentro del
programa y eso significaría un millón de
delitos menos un millón de delitos que
podrían ser ocasionados a sus negocios a
sus casas a sus familias a ustedes los
solucionamos un problema sumamente
importante a través de un modelo de
negocio cuál es el punto aquí hoy en día
estamos viendo
como ya han dicho partes de los speakers
que el mundo se está cayendo a pedazos
hoy realmente estamos viendo algo que se
asemeja así como las películas
apocalípticas
no vemos terremotos inundaciones
incendios forestales de magnitudes
impresionantes cambio climático que se
ve guerras violencia delincuencia
y parece ser que los gobiernos están
totalmente incapacitados o falta de
interés para solucionar estas
problemáticas
y las asociaciones civiles por más que
quieren
pues no ha podido no lo pueden hacer
cada vez hay menos donativos cada vez
esto están más difíciles de lograr esa
solución a través de las asociaciones
civiles
y en mi opinión yo creo que si nosotros
como emprendedores si nosotros como
empresarios no somos capaces de meter a
nuestros modelos de negocio
una generación de impacto positivo y no
estoy siquiera hablando de que sea de
gente privada de la libertad o sea si
los emprendedores en los empresarios
pueden hacer eso
realmente entre todos podríamos tener un
mucho mucho mejor méxico
y hoy lo que les puedo decir es que
aunque yo no quería ser un emprendedor
social hoy no me imagino siendo nada más
que un emprendedor social muchísimas
gracias
[Aplausos]